[Music]
peter king updated his power rankings in
this week's football morning in america
not a lot of change at the bottom or the
top but a lot of shuffling in between
peter which team was your biggest mover
upward
[Music]
uh
my biggest mover upward mike uh and i'm
just looking at the list now my biggest
mover
probably probably was the detroit lions
i put them up to 11
and they had been 27 uh in the offseason
i think
it just shows that matt patricia is
doing a really good job
in sort of building a team
that had so many things to do and so
many holes to fill but also needed a
mental makeover i i
but overall i would say that the biggest
thing i struggled with is who to put
third i just didn't know who to put
third yeah um obviously the chiefs and
the patriots are gonna be one two or two
one i ended up new england one uh chiefs
two
and i put the rams three and i realize
it's obviously
that was one of the worst performances
any good team has ever put on
you know in the super bowl era on sunday
but i just think overall i just view it
as a blip on the radar screen we'll see
but i think everybody else everybody
else had a little zit to a mike
and you know with with the rams we
talked about jared goff and we focused
on the offense wade phillips hasn't
really been mentioned as responsible for
what happened but i see 55 points yes on
the board and i wonder where the hell
was wade phillips defense on sunday
chris yeah no that's a legitimate
question they got torn up the buccaneers
gave a little bit of a formula i think
on how to attack that wade phillips
offense got into some running sets got
big made them play base defense they
couldn't get in diamond nickel and just
use their team speed to fly around and
rush the passer uh and jameis winston
was on fire their o-line didn't let
aaron donald and dante fowler ruined the
game was really one of the biggest
things
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports